but through the conversations meetings
and events that occur to them the work
explores all conceivable aspects of
Jewish life and religion from law and
practice to Theology and of course
esoteric cabalistic speculation it is
the Zohar that serves as the gold
standard for cabala for most of
history there is some disagreement on
who wrote this work the traditional
account within Judaism and cabala is
that it was actually written by shiman
bayai himself in the 2 Century remaining
basically secret to all but a few until
the late 13th century when it was
revealed to the public so to say and the
book is indeed written kind of ancient
Aramaic albe a very flawed and unusual
Aramaic which sort of adds to this image
that it is trying to present of itself
however most Scholars today are pretty
sure that the work was actually composed
in the 13th century by the Spanish Rabbi
and cabalist mosha de Leon